on a appris ce matin le ministère turc
de la défense a annoncé la signature
d'un accord avec la russie sur
l'établissement d'un centre au conjoint
de l'observation le but surveiller le
cessez le feu dans la région
on en parle avec antoine claironnant
travail spécial ans antoine je vais me
dire l'azerbaïdjan est donc entré dans
le dernier des districts ont rétrocédé
par l'arménie un district
particulièrement important les habitants
du haut karabagh oui conformément aux
textes signés le 9 novembre par les
dirigeants azerbaïdjanais arménien et
russe les militaires azerbaïdjanais ont
donc pris qu'on le contrôle ont donc
pris concession de ce district de
latchine et celui ci a ceci de
particulier qu'il comprend sur son
territoire ce couloir de lachine vous
l'avez évoqué rapidement une route
stratégique qui relie ce qu'il reste du
haut karabagh à l'arménie mais le sort
de ce corridor ainsi que celui de la
localité même de latchine reste sujet à
débat en effet le président
azerbaïdjanais compte bien en reprendre
le contrôle et faire construire un autre
passage au passage une route différente
pour relier l'arménie au haut karabagh
un sujet sensible pour le kremlin qui a
préféré ne pas commenter cette
déclaration et même si la rétrocession
des trois anciens des trois districts
anciennement sous contrôle arménien
s'est passé relativement sans heurts la
situation sur place reste néanmoins
assez précaire en témoin donc le cas de
ce corridor de latchine qui relie
l'arménie au haut karabakh mais qui
traversera désormais des territoires
sous contrôle azerbaïdjanais
merci antoine heures pour toutes ces
précisions